the candidates were asked to raise their
hand if they would support Donald Trump
as the Republican nominee if he were
nominated even if he was convicted of a
crime in court The Fakes hand shoots up
first thing Way High
DeSantis keeps his arm down looks at
Vivek sees that his hand went up and
then puts his hand up at least halfway
horrible look and it's a horrible look
not because of the substance I think
DeSantis could have done well on this
question whether he raised his hand or
not he would have done better had he
raised to sand but what even if he had
kept his hand down the key to this
answer was not the substance of Are You
Gonna support Trump or not the the key
to the question is the condition the key
to the question was the speed the
confidence with which you did